-Welcome to the show.
It is very nice to meet you.
-It's nice meeting you as well.
-Did you see me?
Because we were at
the Met Gala last night.
-I did. We made eye contact.
-We kind of did
a little bit, right?
-And then we decided
not to say hi.
[ Laughter ]
We were standing in that line.
-No.
-Yes.
-You were in the line?
-I was in the line.
I saw you in front of me.
And you looked back.
And then we made eye contact.
And I go --
[ Inhales deeply ] No.
-No. Save it.
Save the magic for Charades.
-Exactly.
-Yeah, and I think we did well.
-We did.
-We did well.
-We won.
-Yeah, we totally won.
Are you kidding me?
Of course.
I want to know more about you.
-Okay.
-I know you live in L.A.
Thank you for coming here to do
our show, but --
-Thank you.
-You're from Spokane?
-I am. Spokane, Washington.
-Washington.
-My family loves that you
talk about Gonzaga.
-Yeah! Yeah!
-Tell your family I said hi.
-I will.
-Yeah, Gonzaga.
We were rooting for those kids.
-Yeah, we were so excited.
-Oh, my gosh.
And how do you go from Spokane
to here, to Hollywood?
-I was a little girl with
a big imagination.
-Yeah, a dream.
Just a girl with a dream.
-Yeah, my parents thought
it was like
wanting to be a princess.
That it wasn't real,
you couldn't touch it.
We're a smaller town.
So I put together a five-year
business plan presentation
of what could happen
if they let me.
-Did you really?
-I did.
-I love this.
-Yeah. They took me seriously.
-A PowerPoint?
-A PowerPoint presentation.
-For your parents.
-For my parents.
-Like, "Hey,
if you let me do this,
here's what I'll do.
I'll make money here
and I'll live here."
-I was, like, 11,
and they listened.
-How did you have a plan?
How did you research it?
-I just googled a lot.
-Yeah, on how to do it.
-Google has
a lot of information.
-Yeah. And did it take
five years or...?
-It took a little longer.
-Yeah.
-Was it the struggle
you imagined? Or is it --
-It was a little harder
than I imagined.
-It's very -- It's tough.
-It is.
It's tough to make it.
-It's not as glamorous
as you think it is.
-No, I mean, for some
people, you know, it is.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Okay.
-It is a struggle, though.
But it's a lot of work that
no one tells you really about.
But you go from that PowerPoint
to being on
the biggest show on TV.
-Oh, gosh. Stop.
-"Euphoria."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-That's got to feel great.
The first season was hit.
And everyone's going,
"We love it."
Then second season,
I think, just took off.
Became a whole show of its own.
-It did.
It became, like, it's own beast.
-I know that it just exploded,
and everyone's talking about it.
Everyone in our office
was talking about it,
and it became very big
as far as memes go.
-It did.
-Yeah.
You're very --
-It became very memable.
-You're a very memable show.
Of course, the "never ever
been happier" meme.
-Yes.
-Look at you, though.
-I have sent that to my mom.
-You sent this --
-I sent that one to my mom.
[ Laughter ]
-And did she laugh?
Did she love it?
-Yeah, she liked that one.
-Yeah,
you've never been happier.
Do you like doing
these dramatic scenes?
Like, how do you --
-I love them.
What's crazy,
though, is this scene
was the first scene we filmed
coming back for season 2.
So, we had an entire
year and a half break,
and then that was
the first scene we did.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-And did you know it
was going to be --
No idea.
-They just put it in
different spots?
-I didn't know how it would be.
-Yeah.
I forgot about this scene.
-We filmed for, like, almost
a year and then watched it.
-And then there it is.
Well, there's another meme
here, too.
This is Cassie,
your character Cassie.
And this is when you were in the
bathtub at the party, hiding.
Oh, no.
-"Me when the DoorDash person
knocks instead of just
leaving the food there."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm not here!"
I'm not --
-But why is this so accurate?
Why is this so accurate?
-It's almost like --
I'm like that
sometimes on Halloween.
I'm like, "Alright, I gave
enough, trick or treaters.
Let's go.
We're sleeping, we're sleeping."
-Why are we so scared of them?
-I don't know. Just, come on.
Just drop the food off.
We had a deal.
This one, I love.
This is "Cassie in high school
versus me in high school."
-Oh, no.
-And everyone has done this.
[ Laughter ]
Because just the way the
characters dress on "Euphoria."
-They got their [bleep]
together.
-Yeah, I mean, yes, they do.
You can't say that on our show.
-Oh, I'm so sorry.
-Yeah, no problem.
You can't say "together."
You have to say --
This just made me laugh,
and then
everyone started doing it.
And then, I told you that
we were going to
do this meme thing.
And so you said,
"I'll help out," so...
-Oh, no!
-This is a picture of
you in high school.
This is Cassie in high school
versus you in high school.
Not --
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go!
-Oh, no!
-That's real!
Come on, you're so cute.
Come on, buddy.
-Oh, man.
The best part, too,
are my shoes.
-What are you wearing?
-I'm wearing, like, Army boots.
-Yes!
And how old are you there?
-It's an old sweatshirt.
Because my family, we do
Christmas sweatshirts
every year.
So, it's old.
But that was sophomore year.
-Sophomore year.
Look at you now.
I want to show everyone how
incredible you are
in "Euphoria."
You're really great.
Congratulations on that.
Thank you.
-I'm a big fan.
Please come back.
Here's Sydney Sweeney
in "Euphoria."
Take a look at this.
-I deserve this, right?
-Oh, my God.
Please, Mom, stop.
-I deserve this.
-Mom! Mom, stop!
-You stop it.
-Lexi, I'm going to ...
kill you.
I deserve this, right?
Because I've actually
lived a life.
-Mom?
-I'm the one who takes risks.
-Show us your boobs.
-I'm the one who falls in love.
-I'm the one who gets hurt,
not you, Lexi.
[ Crowd murmurs ]
You never even ... lived.
That's why you're able to stand
up here and judge all of us!
You're just a ... bystander.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sydney Sweeney, everybody.
Seasons 1 and 2 of "Euphoria"
are streaming now on HBO Max.